hi my name is Wyatt knocks Wyatt knocks
is an American Rally Champion and today
I'm breaking down more eclipses for
movies and TV about driving all-wheel
drive car control baby driver
[Music]
[Applause]
so an all-wheel-drive turbocharged car
is gonna have a distinct advantage over
a two-wheel drive car whether you have a
front-wheel drive car or a rear-wheel
drive car you need to put all of your
power through those wheels in order to
get traction and go we're an all-wheel
drive car with all wheels driven you can
have more power a turbocharged engine
like this and to put a lot of power down
and get actual acceleration instead of
just wheel spin
[Music]
[Applause]
it's also really nice to see that
they've got a lot of the kind of clips
to foot and hands and things inside the
car pretty spot-on in this I mean the
driving is highly exaggerated if you
were you know running away from a bank
robbery you're not just gonna be
chucking at this sideways but for the
sake of what it is it's on point
corkscrew jump the man with the Golden
Gun
[Music]
so this junk believe it or not is
completely legit so it looks here like
the driver kind of takes off and goes
right off this jump I'm sure there was a
longer run-up and the driver had a
little bit of time to get up to speed
find a steady speed and then really just
accelerate smoothly off of it it was
really well planned out as far as the
curvature of things and the distance and
the calculated speed they actually
slowed the clip down a little bit for
the movie just because it happened so
fast in real time I had a little slide
whistle over it and it's good to go
neither by actually car chase through
San Francisco bullet
[Music]
so the thing about San Francisco is as a
driver you've got these steep uphill
steep downhills big off cambered corners
and obviously the jumps that make this
car chase so famous this seems legendary
and I don't have too much bad to say
about it the one thing you will notice
is the little green Volkswagen need some
information they go by that beetle at
least four times in this car chase
other than that fantastic driving really
good stuff there's the great Volkswagen
there's the green Volkswagen there's the
green Volkswagen there's a game modes
like it right the only thing I've had to
save up a whole day pit maneuver
fast and furious
[Applause]
in any sort of normal form of motorsport
this would be taking your license away
and you'd be black flag forever you
can't be good for business yeah well
that depends on how you look at things
essentially a pit maneuver is when you
hit the rear quarter-panel of another
car with the intention of spinning them
out and around and crashing them so you
can keep going it's definitely something
to be avoided it's not that big a danger
of crashing and going off the road but
what you'll see is especially your front
fenders bend in and get bound up on
those tires real easily and then you're
just giving yourself a flat tire and
giving yourself a lot of problems down
the road you're lucky man though you're
still breathing you're a lot better off
just driving faster but you know illegal
street racing is what it is
sling shot Talladega Nights link shot
engage
rival robber passive teammate in order
to understand drafting it's easy to
think about one car traveling through
the air the resistance of pushing
through all that air at the front of the
car but then also at the back if you
have two or three cars on the same team
out there you can do a lot to help each
other out
using that drafting phenomenon it's just
exciting that we're trying to think like
yeah so the slingshot move there's two
ways to do it the way that they do it
here the two cars line up both of those
cars are now gaining a bit of an
advantage on that lead car I'm not sure
what to do with my hand as the two cars
approach the lead car the rear car comes
out and has a bit of a burst of speed
for a moment to try and overtake that
lead car we're real happy with them with
what was going on what's also very
common in NASCAR is when you get three
cars close together that lead car has a
lot of drag on the front and the rear
car has a lot of drag on the back but
that middle car sort of just in a
slipstream for a second that's going to
give him a really good potential
acceleration for a moment and if they
capitalize on that you can get that pass
where you might not be able otherwise to
have the horsepower to do so thank you
we find it like handbrake turn die hard
with a vengeance
I mean it's pretty good it's conceivable
that with enough speed if you did a
handbrake turn on a wet paved road like
that you could get the car to do a 360
because I'm no expert on you know
shooting out the window left-handed
while you were trying to pull it off but
you would definitely want to get rid of
any ABS stability control traction
control and that kind of stuff if you
try that in a modern car with the ABS
still active and that kind of thing it's
just not gonna work pin break turn
vacation
all right so this is computer-generated
but it does depict a pretty real
scenario so this is the fast and furious
syndrome if in diesel can do it so can i
things that are exaggerated through
movies give people a little bit of the
wrong idea on what works and what
doesn't so in a sports car or a rally
car something kind of low slung and wide
you get away with sliding around and
chucking it sideways and doing handbrake
turns and things like that anything
that's a little bit narrower and a
little bit taller you've got a much
higher center of gravity that your risk
of rollover is much much higher that's
not what I was trying to do off-road
driving the Dukes of Hazzard
[Music]
high-speed driving on some of these
rougher surfaces like they're doing here
with the old charger the main risk is
going to be flat tires broken suspension
parts and definitely damaging kind of
the soft underbelly of your car and your
tires well I guess there are definitely
measures that you can take to protect
you know skid plates underneath the car
heavy-duty suspension heavy-duty tires
maybe a little extra air pressure it's
all real driving back that and honestly
it's really pretty good car chase Ronin
[Music]
high-speed pursuits in narrow city
streets like this chase through Paris
there's a lot of curbs there's a lot of
obstacles vegetable carts as they love
in the movie chase scenes and everything
else nice okay my kind of job the
biggest key is really just always
looking for your opening in your window
and your gap and your spot where you can
fit the car why it's your human instinct
a lot of times to be looking at the
pedestrian and the vegetable cargo to
know just like skiing or mountain biking
or anything else you know if you look at
the bad things you hit the bad things
you look in the good places you go in
the good places car chase through a mall
the Blues Brothers you got us into this
parking lot
answered burgers yeah lots of space in
this mall so there's not a lot not to
love about the Blues brothers chased
through them all there's nothing in
there that your normal car couldn't
really do
they drove through a lot of glass so you
might get a flat tire but there wasn't
really you know computer stuff back then
to really fake anything with looks like
a lot of fun
chopper some constructive criticism
should have put their seat belts on
that's all to say about that one burn
out the transporter
[Music]
the foot camera of doing that burnout
isn't exactly right in order to do that
burnout you'd either need to rev the
engine dump the clutch and quickly left
foot brake specific dumping the clutch
is when you rev the engine and quickly
release the clutch in order to shock
load those rear tires and give them a
lot of quick acceleration to get them to
break traction and start spinning long
speeches just keep it simple or manage
both those tasks with just your right
foot and heel and toe it to stay still
doing a burnout but also you know
obviously once he tries to jump the
bridge it all just goes into
computer-generated land and he lands on
a trailer and magically drives away
very good spikes on the hub caps grease
the idea of putting spikes on your
hubcaps to try and get into someone
else's bodywork and their wheels and
tires and disabled their vehicle well
it's sort of bad sportsmanship I suppose
yeah so what you find though is that he
only mounted them kind of to its hubcaps
and so when they really needed them they
kind of fell off and you probably
wouldn't want to make it out of aluminum
like you see this one is is gonna crack
and break apart pretty easily you
probably want to use some high-strength
steel bolted through your lug nuts you'd
have some useful wheel spikes horsepower
the fate of the Furious we've got up
about 2,000 horsepower in that thing
drop 3,000
ah two things on that one as long as
both rear tires are spinning it doesn't
matter if you have 2,000 horsepower
20,000 horsepower
he's not getting any traction on the
road he's not getting any grip he's not
pulling anyone anywhere at that point
some about this whole thing that just
doesn't have up to me he might have 500
horsepower
he could have closer to a thousand
perhaps and in this situation where
you're trying to pull something it's the
difference between horsepower and torque
is where you really might want to spend
a little bit of time doing some homework
I'm gonna keep it about the cars
acceleration at higher speeds you're
worried about horsepower but really
pulling and moving and getting things
going you need a huge amount of torque
jumping a car the Dukes of Hazzard
[Music]
one of the mainstays of the old Dukes of
Hazzard were these massive car jumps 30
40 feet in the air and everybody lands
and drives away like they're fine
helicopters many helicopters jumping a
car is just like jumping anything else
what you need is a pretty smooth takeoff
and then a nice smooth downhill landing
right before they go off the jump the
driver takes his hands off the wheel and
puts one sort of like in the middle of
the wheel like this something you never
really want to do good hand position
always especially in that situation sure
don't be a player too with you the real
professionally yeah
but you definitely want to be at the
right angle on the takeoff on the
throttle with a nice smooth landing on
the way out in order to accomplish that
successfully with a car crashing a car
Spector
[Music]
so he drives off a little jump in an
Aston Martin and rips the entire top off
another car without doing any damage to
his completely fake so in almost every
vehicle in the world you've got a B and
C pillars you're a pillars are the
pillars on either side of your
windshield those strong metal bars that
go up and support the roof by your doors
you've got the B pillars kind of on your
shoulder length those are the B pillars
and the C pillars if you have them if
you've got you know not a really small
car would be in the back again those
rear most pillars that support the roof
structure those a B and C pillars are
some of the strongest points of your car
so that if your cars roll over it
doesn't just crumple the idea of an
aston martin cruising through there with
his bumper cover still intact is not
realistic driving down the stairs the
Bourne Identity
so this is a great car chase it's all
real driving there's no kind of CG stuff
going on I'm just trying to do the right
thing as far as the mini it's cool to
see in a movie like this because in a
real situation you're not gonna be
driving you know the Astin's and the
Jaguars and the real you know Bugattis
or whatever it is you want to drive what
everybody else is driving I got to
figure this out whether or not a vehicle
will be able to drive up or down stairs
really you're looking at the approach
angle which is the angle you'll be able
to drive up something between the bumper
and the tire the breakover angle which
is in the middle and then your departure
angle which is the same thing line
between your rear bumper and the bottom
of your rear tire that roughly tells you
how much of an incline you could drive
up or down or over you wouldn't
obviously want to take off the top quite
as quickly as they did you know go a
little easier and roll over and same
thing at the bottom for driving down
staircases and over things like that a
little mini it's actually a really good
way to go
conclusion as much fun as it is to kind
of poke around and see what could be
more realistic if you adhered by all of
the actual laws of physics in the world
a lot of these car chases would be
really boring
if one car spins out and the other ones
just gone and that's the end of the
scene nobody wants to watch that the way
that they're filming some of these
action chases today is pretty
spectacular to watch and really enjoy a
lot of it just as a viewer
[Applause]
[Music]